2ページにこのアーナーパーナパッバンニッティタンという
まあ私の覚えから言えばね
おそらく呼吸瞑想の方は全部終わったと思います
それは呼吸瞑想終わったところはアーナーパーナパッバンと書いてます
あの5番目打ってるところの上
それから次に5番目ありまして
プナチャパラン
ビッキャウェ ビックー ガッチャントーワ ガッチャミーティ パジャーナーティ ティトーワ ティトーミーティ パジャーナー
ティ ニシンノーワ ニシンノーミーティ パジャーナーティ サヤーノーワ サヤーノーミーティ パジャーナーティ
ヤター ヤターワ パナッサカーヨー パニヒトーホーティ タター タター ナン パジャーナーティという
もう一つ体について瞑想する方法なんですね
で プナチャパラン ビッキャウェ ビックー
またビクラよ ビックーガッチャントーワ ビックー
比丘がガッチャントーワ
歩く時はガッチャミーティ
まあ歩いてました パジャーナーティ
知ると 知る ティトー 立っている時
立ってる時はティトーミ
立ってるんだと まあ確認するんですね
パジャーナーティっていうのはそういうこと
ニシンノーっていうのは座ってる時
ニシンノーミーティ 今座ってると確認する
サヤーノーっていうのは横になっている時
横になってると知る ヤターヤターワ パナッサカーヨー パニヒトーホーティ
ヤターヤター まあいろいろ方法ということで
自分のパナアッサ 彼のカーヨー体をパニヒトーホーティ
まあ動かしているならば
いろいろどのどのどのように体を動かしているならば
そのようにタタータタ
それナン それをパジャーナーティ確認する
で 体に関してサティの実践というのは
もう2番目はこれなんですね
体の動きを観察するっていうことなんですね
だから一番メインになるのは
行住サガという 歩く 立つ
座る 横になるということ
その4つをやってると
もう体の動きを今こういうこと
今こういう動き 今こういう動きですよと一つ一つ確認する
ですから その行住サガ4つだけなんですけど
それでない時もありますね
だから他の体の動きもありますね
それはヤターヤターワ パナッサカーヨー パニヒトーホーティ
他の体の動きでもあるならば
その体の動きも確認すると
例えば座っていて 手なんか足なんか動かしたりする場合は
それを確認するとか 例えば立っていて頭でもかいでるんだったら
それは違う動きですから
それをまた確認すると
そのように体の動きを確認することも一つのサティの実践方法なんですね
で それからそれで終わるんじゃなくて
いつでもこの あの決まってるシステムがありますから
見方 イティアッジャッタンワカーエ カヤーヌパッシー ヴィヘルティ
アッジャッタンカーエ
自分の体に 内なる体について
そのように体に沿って見ながら生活する
確認しながら生活する
バイッダーワカーエ 体から外のことも同じやり方で確認していくと
この場合は他の人の歩き方
座り方かもしれません
で それからアッジャッタバイッダーワカーエ
自分の体であろうとも
他人の体であろうとも
まあそういう動きしかないんだよということをね
まとめてみる 生命だったら歩く
立つ 座る また横になる
またいろいろ行動やってる
まあそれしか体の行動はないのではないかということを確認してみると
それからサムデーダンマーヌパッシー
その一つ一つの現象 行動
動きをどのように表れますかと
歩くということはどのようなことですかとかね
で 座るということはどのような働きですかとかね
で それをまた一つ一つ確認していく
で ヴァヤダンマ その後消えること
それも確認していく ヴァヤダンマヌパッシーカヤスミンギヘル
それから両方まとめてサムデヴァヤ
現れることと消えることを両方確認していくという体の動きの瞑想なんですね
で そこでこの例えば歩くことを観察するならば
まあ歩くということはどういうことか
歩くという現象がどのように現れますかということにも理解いかなくちゃならないんですね
だからずっとやり続けると
大体まあ自動的にそういうのは気付く場合もあるし
まあそう気づかない場合はそのように進めていかなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この歩いてますよと言ったら
ずいぶん大雑把であまりにもまとめすぎなんですね
たくさん行動は ですから
最初はまあ歩いてますよぐらいだけでもいいんですね
それからまあ左 右って分けてもよろしいし
それから上げます 運んでいます
下ろしますで分けてもよろしいし
で それから上げるということはどういうことかと
こういうことで上げると
こういうことで運ぶと
こういうことで下ろすと
で それはもっとさらに明確に明確に持っていく
で そうすると歩くということはわかるんです
それから 他の人の視点も
他の生命にしても 同じことで歩いているんだよと
だからムカデとかどのように観察すればいいかちょっとわかりにくいんだけど
足がいっぱい生えてるんだから
で まあ人間同じくもう猿とかは簡単ですけどね
まあ犬とか猫とかもうちょっと難しいんですね
足４本ついてますからね
まあそれでもある意味では歩いてますよ
では見てみれば で 大体はね
まあ４本の足の動物の場合はね
前の右足上先に行っていると
後ろの右足がどこにありますか
後ろ 見てないんだから
ものすごいあるリズム感に左と右分けてちゃんと歩いてますよ
そうでないと歩けないんだからね
例えば前の左足を前につけて
前の後ろの左足が後ろだったらもうこうなってるんですから歩けないんです
だから両方もう前に行くんです
で 少々リズム違う歩き方もあります
そのその動物によって
で 早く歩く場合は 動物を早く歩く場合は前と後ろで歩いてるんですね
前足両方いっぺんに持っていって体飛ばして飛ばして行くんですね
馬もそうでしょうし で
馬見ればすごいわかりやすいし
飛んでいくんですね だからその場合は
二本の足の働きで早く歩くっていうのは走ることだからね
歩いているし 大体は左半分持っていって
右半分持っている 左半分持っていって右半分持っているっていうふうなやり方なんです
人間も大体同じやり方で
ですから 四本の足の動物を観察することも結構難しいんですけど
だからムカデはおそらく無理でしょう
で それは難しいんだけど
ヘビはもっと難しいと思いますけど
ヘビにもゆっくり歩く方
早く歩く方 二種類あります
で ヘビにしたっても足はないんだけど
何て言います？スケールスありますから
それで歩いてるんですね
ゆっくり歩く場合はね
ですから そこはこの前と後ろ
前と後ろと前と後ろとね
で動いてるんで それで歩いてるし
それでこの前に出す力が足らないんだから
体をこの左 右にこねちゃうというかね
持っていくんですね それはゆっくり歩く時
ものすごいゆっくり歩く時は体をこねる必要はないんで
そのままずっと前に前に進みます
すごい早く歩くときはどうやってヘビが歩くんですかね
その時は体のひねり 骨だけ使って歩くんです
で 体曲がって飛ばしちゃうんですね
あのスケールは使わない
どっちにしたっても単純なある基本的な動きでみんな歩いてるんです
それは結局このまあ この膨らみ縮みの機能なんですよ
魚にしたってもね 歩くって言って泳ぐっていうことだから
やっぱりあのヘビと同じくこのひねる体くねくねて前に持っていっちゃうし
大体あるのは筋肉の立場から見ると
もう縮むことと伸ばすことだけなんですね
だから歩き方として勉強しちゃうと大変な難しいかもしれませんだけど
結局基本的にあるのは筋肉の伸びと縮みだけ
で それだけのことでいろいろ歩き方できる
それで自分と他人のもう歩き方観察したりして
そこで どのように現れるかというと
縮んでる筋肉は伸ばすこと
伸ばしてる筋肉は縮むことで歩きが始まるんですね
歩きの消え方といえば同じことなんですね
ですから 右足を持っていって
一旦下ろしたら そちらの仕事終わっちゃうでしょうし
それで左足の動きが始まるんですね
とにかくそこはどんな瞑想でも全部完璧にできるということはないんだけど
一応ね 観察するものは自分の体と他人の体と
それから現れる両方をまとめて見ること
それから現れることを見ること
消えることを見ること
また現れる消えることはまとめて見るという 4つの方法でやらなくちゃいけないんです
そこでまあ こんな体ですよということを
まあただそれだけですよという智慧が出てくるんです
大したことないんだと
あまり単純だと だから巨大な知識がいるんじゃなくて
知識飛んじゃうんですね
なくなっちゃうんです
これだけかと というニャーナマッターへ
その微かな智慧が生まれてくる
アッティカーヨーティワパナスサティパッチュパッティターホーティ
だから人間の歩き方にしても
もう例えばこの歌舞伎やら能やら
そういう芸術だったら
もうものすごい訓練しなくちゃいけない
修行しなくちゃいけない
泣きながらこの あの連中が何て言いますか
このモデルさんとかね
歩き方は訓練するはするは
だからモデルの人々はね
自分服着る服に合わせて歩き方調整しなくちゃいけないしね
だからまあこの場合はこういう歩き方ですよ
この場合はこういう歩き方ですよとかね
で 歌舞伎やら能やら そういう技術芸術にしたっても
いろいろ歩き方あって
そういう風に見るともう大変な世界なんです
すごい訓練もしなくちゃいけない世界
それは現象から見ると
幻覚の世界から見ると
こう歩いたらカッコよく映りますよと
こういう風に歩いたら悲しみの表現できますよと
こういう風に歩けば勇気とか勇気の表現できますよと
歌舞伎なんかそんなものだからね
こういう風に歩く歩くと
もう憎しみやら恨みやら
そういう表現できますよと
ですから この舞台へ出てくるヒーローの歩き方
それから悪人 悪役の人の歩き方とか
まあ決めてやること きめ細かく
で それを幻覚の世界だけなんですね
だからそうすると大変なたくさん知識ばっかし増えちゃうんですね
じゃあ能の人と能舞台で歩く歩き方と
現代風なモデルさんの歩き方
どう違いますかとかね
で 能歌舞伎の世界でもすごい堂々たる姿が現れる時もあるでしょうね
で その歩き方と じゃあ現代のモデルさんたちの歩き方どうですかと
これまだ随分違うでしょうしね
そういう風になっちゃうと
きめ細かく勉強しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃって
知識が増えるだけ そう
苦しみが生まれてくるだけ
例えばやっぱりもう 1週間も練習しているんだけど
まだまだうまくいかないんだとかね
だからモデルの女の子なんか泣くんだからね
もううまくいかないっていうことで
そこでストレスたまったりして
精神安定剤まで飲んだりして
何時間も何時間も歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いて
もうまたダメ またダメ
そちらダメ こちらダメとかね
言われて叱られっぱなしで
ということは そちらにはもう幻想
幻覚の世界に入っちゃうと
そこにあるのは苦しみだけなんですね
何か大した結果あるかといったら
そんなもんかと見てみれば
それだけのことなんですね
じゃあ歌舞伎とか能とか見てる人々はそんなにきめ細かく見ているんですかね
こういう歩き方で こういう表現ですよ
こういう歩き方 こういう見てないと思いますけどね
私はバカだから見ますから
きめ細かく でもみんな感動して拍手でもしますけど
あの片足で歩いたりするとね
あの歌舞伎役者が  1つの足を上げて片足で飛んでるでしょ？横にカニみたいに
みんなよく拍手するんですね
なぜかわかりませんだけど
能の場合はやっぱりこの
もうほとんど波の動きでしょうね
表現しようとしてるのも足が上げられませんだからね
足を上げないと 足を滑って滑って歩くんで
滑ると言ったってもたくさん滑れません
もう足の長さの半分か 4分の1ぐらいしか滑らせません
それぐらい滑ら滑らして歩くんですから
それでもやっぱり自分演じている役柄に合わせて
そこら辺ですごいきめ細かい調整するんですね
だから見ている人には歩いているではなくて
まあ何と言いますか もう波のように動いているんだというふうにこの錯覚を起こそうと思って
だからきめ細かく見ない人にはその錯覚は起こるんですけどね
私にとってはあの仮面がもうちょっと大きくした方がいいんじゃないかなと
鼻と目の方で終わっちゃうんですね
だからこれ昔の日本人
体小さかったんだから
今は体でっかいんだからね
仮面が合わないんですね
だから気持ち悪くて えらい研究するんだけど
そこら辺はもうまたもう滑っちゃうんですね
能と何か伝統だ伝統だと言いながら
そういうふうな世界で
人間の世界から歩く方を見ちゃうと
貪瞋痴の世界で見ているんだから
確実にあるのは苦しみなんですね
自分がどのように歩けば美しいですかとかね
そういう苦しみだけ それで一般の人は歩き方訓練もしてないんだから
まず歩き方は全く下手でしょうし
だから歩くと腰が痛いし
今は私も腰が痛いんだけど
座り方が悪いんだ 何時間もね
変に座ってコンピューターやってますから
まあで歩き方悪い時はね
まあ腰が痛いし 背骨が曲がっちゃうしね
また手の手の振り方一番嫌なんですね
周りはもう誰もいけないぐらい
もうなんであんな激しく手を振るんですかと
だから全然気がついてないんですね
もうこれは悪いということさえも迷惑だと
みんなにこの狭い道でものすごい両手伸ばして振っちゃうと他の人は行けないんだから
特に私がもう乗り起こして行きたいんだけど
なかなかできなくて まあ普通の人
歩き方の訓練してないんだから
それでもってまたいろいろ知らないうちに苦労している
じゃあ歩き方勉強する人々はどうです？それは貪瞋痴の世界だから
いろんな苦労 苦しみが出てくる
たくさんのことを覚えなくちゃいけない
習わなくちゃいけない
知識を通して積み重ねなくちゃいけないと
だから知恵の答えは何ですか？というと
ただそれだけですと という知恵なんですね
能役者歩こうが 歌舞伎役者歩こうが
ヘビが歩こうが 魚が泳ごうが
たった一つの行動しかないんだ
ただ単に筋肉の縮みて伸ばす
それだけのことなんです
それで現象の世界では
幻覚の世界ではすごい知識いっぱい作ってものすごい苦しんでるんですね
ですから まあそういう風にこのただこれだけという風な智慧が生まれてくるのだ
これこの何とかテキスト間違ってるような感じがします
やわでなニャーなまったや
パティッスティマッターヤ
テキストは違うんではなくて
パティッスティのところで点が間違っています M
は大文字ではなくて小文字のmなんですね
パティッスティマッターヤ
パティッスティっていうのは
これ あの まあサティということで落ち着くっていうことなんですね
そこでほんのわずかなこの智慧が生まれてくる
だから智慧も軽く見て
ほんのちょっと あ ただそれだけかっていうぐらいのことなんです
それで全ての苦しみが消えちゃいますから
この軽く見ることで それだけかと
そんなもんかと それが智慧なんです
そういうことですよっていうのは知識であって智慧ではないんです
こういうことで こういうことで
こういうことで こういうこと
こういうことですよと結論を出すのは知識であって
これすごく重いんです
そんなもんかということは智慧の世界
言葉で言うならばそんな差なんですね
だから智慧っていうのはない世界でなくす世界なんですね
そんなもんかと見れば軽いでしょうに
例えばモデルさん訓練すると言ったって
そんなもんかと分かればすぐできるでしょ
分かればもうすぐできますから
だから智慧の人には知識っていうのは何のことないんです
だから物事ってそんなもんかという感じで見なくちゃいけないんですね
だからそれただの真似したってもできませんだからね
それなりのちゃんと修行して智慧を発達させてないとできないんですけどね
だから まあ物に価値入れるとすごい理解しにくいんです
映画見ることにしたって
すごい映画ですよと見ると
結局見てないことになっちゃうんですね
まるっきり何の価値も何の意味もないんだと
くだらんだという立場で見ると
きび細かく細部に見られる
見ようとすれば ですから
智慧でもって全ての知識捨てた人にとっては
どんな知識でも得ようとすればとても簡単に得られるし
得たっても即座に捨てちゃうし
知識だけの人にはもう全てを知ることはできません
何か知ったらそれの重さで頭いっぱい
それ以上勉強できなくなっちゃうんです
だから歌舞伎役者は一生歌舞伎しか知りません
他の踊り まあ踊り上手かもしれませんだけど
あの西洋的なあのコリオグラフなんかやってもできません
あの踊りとかブレイクダンスとかね
いくら歌舞伎役者もう子供の頃からもう訓練しているんだけど
ブレイクダンスは無理
ですから この知識っていうのはそういうもので
まああれは体に慣れるものなんですけど
まあ他の知識も同じなんですね
数学を専門的に勉強する人には歴史は無理でしょうしね
だから世の中で専門的な分野が出てきてね
そういう各専門の世界でみんな一生かけて頑張っちゃうしね
だから知識だけ追っていくとかなり難しいんですね
まあ知恵って見るとそんなことはなくてね
やろうとすればできるっていうことでね
ですから このニャーナマッタ
このマッタっていうのはこのスライド
ほんの少々 ほんのわずかって意味なんですね
この僅かなこの知恵が生まれてくるんですね
この僅かなこの知恵でもってパティスティ
パティスティっていうのはサティがあるという意味なんですけど
それよりは落ち着き 心の安らぎと理解した方がもっといいかもしれません
それで心にほんのわずかな落ち着きが出てきますね
それでアニッストーチャヴィーヘルティ
アニッストーっていうのは束縛なく
執着なし なき 囚われることなくヴィーヘルティ生活します
別に囚われることはない
ナチャキンチローケウパアディエティ
この世の中で何も別に執着は執着はしませんと
エワンピコブッケウェーカーエカーヤヌパッシリ
これも体の観察する一つの方法ですよ
この意義の観察 行住定慧の意義の観察やってもこのほんのわずかなこの知恵が生まれてくるんだと
次にあるのはと これ承知の部分と訳してますけどね
なんで承知って言うんですかな
次のパーリ語ではイリアパタじゃなくてイリアパタパッバンって終わった
えーと ニバンと サンパジャンニャパッバン
まあなるほどというところなんですけど
じゃあ説明に行きます
番目振っているところから見てください
プナ
チャパランビッケウェービッコーアビッカンテーパティッカンテーサンパジャナカーリーホーティアーローキテーヴィローキテーサンパジャナカーリーホーティサンビン
ジテーパサーリテーサンパジャナカーリーホーティサンガータパッタチーバラダーネサンパジャナカーリーホーティアシテーピーテーカーイテーサーイテーサンパジャナ
カーリーホーティーウッチャーラパッサーヴァカッメサンパジャナカーリーホーティガテーティテーニシンネスッテージャーガリテーバーサティトゥンニーバーウェーサンパジャナカーリーホーティという
ところ
で それだけじゃなくて
体の瞑想するもう一つ方法ありますと
アビッカンテーパティッカンテー
アビッカンタっていうのは前に進むということ
で パティッカンタっていうのはまあ後ろに下がること
で この場合はサンパジャナカーリーホーティ
よく気づいて前に進む時も気づいている
後ろに下がる時もちゃんと気づいている
アーローキトヴィローキテー
アーローキタっていうのは見るという
まあまっすぐ見ること
ヴィローキタっていうのは
まあ横にして見ることかな
訳はどうですか まっすぐ見るにも
あちこち見るにもと書いていますね
しっかり見る時もよく気づいて見る
首をあちこち回りながら見る時も
いわゆるちらちらと見る時でも
それはちゃんと承知の上で見る
だからそう読むんですかね
そこで三身じてパサアレテ
三身じたっていうのは
曲げるにも伸ばすにも
だから体いろいろ曲げたりする
曲げる時もちゃんと承知しながら
よく知りながら確認しながら
気づきながら体を曲げる
体を伸ばす時もちゃんと気づきながら体を伸ばす
こういうことをやってみると
ものすごく知恵が発達します
だから頭にはもう休みなく頭が動いてますからね
だからこの私はこの瞑想を教える時でも
この脳細胞全部使ってくださいと
全部使わないと全部どれまで使ってるかわかりませんだけど
一応言葉だけでもね で
普通に使う集中力では足りません
普通に我々は料理作る時でも
もう何かやってる時のものすごい散漫している
散らかしている あっちこっちにね
ディスプレイスというかね
そうやって散らばっている集中力でしょ
ずっとそこを見ようということはしませんからね
ですから この それで一つだけじっと見ちゃうと
他のことを忘れてしまう
それは気持ちはいいんだけど
集中力だから それだけで知恵は開発しません
例えば本を読むと全て忘れて座ってることも
立ってることも全て忘れて本を読むとちゃんと読めるし
気持ちもいいんです だから人間
この音楽聴くことやらね
テレビ見ることやら なぜよくやってますかというと
ゲームやらね これ集中力できるんだからなんです
別にゲームというのは何の楽しみあるものじゃないんです
くだらなくてバカバカしいんですけど
やっぱりそれに集中力が生まれちゃうんですね
ゲームやってると それでみんな刺激を感じちゃうんですね
楽しいと だから世間話ではなくて
噂話する時でも ゲームやってる時でも
テレビを見てる時でも
映画を見ている時でも
みんなもう全然時間気にしないでじっとやっちゃいますね
それ楽しいという その楽しみっていうのは集中力から生まれてくるんです
ですから この人間のこの喜悦感
快楽感というのは集中力から生まれるものなんです
だから集中力を育てれば
もうものす すごい楽しく
すごい楽しく生活はできます
つまらないとかね だから鬱とかはまるっきり生まれないはずなんですね
悩みとかね 集中力さえあれば
だから幸福になりたいと楽しみたい
人生楽しみたいと思うならば
ただ育てるべきのは集中力なんですね
科学的に言えば 楽しみだからとゲームをやったり
酒も飲んだり 踊りにも行ったり
ディスコにも行ったり
またテレビを見たり また本も読んだりとかいうと
それはもう無茶苦茶でもう切りがないんですね
いつでも依存症で何かやらなくてはならないということで
だからなぜそういうことを楽しみかというと
その時もわずかにでも集中力が生まれてくる
じゃあ集中力しないでゲームやってみてください
いかに面白くないかというと
ですから その時は面白くないんですね
例えば映画館に行って
あのポケットの小さな懐中電灯ありますね
あれを持っていって 本も持っていって
まあ本番というんですか
あれがやり始めたら自分で本を読むと
あの小さな懐中電灯で
いかにつまらないかというと
そうすると映画館というのはものすごい居心地の悪い場所なんです
あの小さな懐中電灯だから
隣の人に迷惑はないし
あの人見てないんだから上見てるんだからね
全然迷惑はないんです
だから他人に迷惑ないんだから実験してみてください
お金かかりますけど  八百円ぐらい
ペンライト買わないと
それは買わなくて それは二百円ぐらいです
で 電車代 そういう三つでしょ
だからそういうことをやっちゃうと
映画館ってのはものすごい居心地の悪い場所なんですね
この椅子は本当に座りにくいんだと
その時初めて感じるんです
そこでまたすごくうるさい
だから音がもうサラウンドだから
上前から横から後ろから入ってくるし
で そういういろいろ問題が出て
集中力が生まれてこないんですね
そうすると 本を読むことは面白くなくなっちゃう
そこをやめて ただスクリーンだけ見ていると
あのバカでかい音も全然気にならないし
楽しくなっちゃうんですね
そこにのめり込んじゃったら
ということだから 楽しみっていうのは集中力にあるんですよ
だから すごい論理的な科学的な答えなんです
映画に楽しみがあるんじゃなくて
集中力があるんだと もし映画に楽しみがあるんだったら
どんな映画もいいでしょうし
そうではないでしょうね
自分で選ぶんだから 音楽は楽しいというならば
どんな音楽でもいいでしょうね
でもそうではないでしょうし
選ぶでしょうし なぜ選ぶかというと
自分にはのめり込めるのはどっちかということなんですね
ですから 世の中の人々はね
ああいう映画はあんまり良くないとか
品格がないんですよとかの映画にもあります
すごい激しい上下関係なんかはね
で まあいろいろいっぱい賞をもらう映画も
一つももらわない映画も
売れる映画も 売れない映画もね
だいたい売れない映画の場合は
かなり芸術的にはすごいレベル高いんだとかね
まあいろいろ言ったりはしますけど
で あまりそういう意味よりも
見る人はそれのめり込めるかないかっていうぐらいで決めるもんなんですね
だから苦労しながらクラシック音楽を聴く必要ないんです
自分に面白くないんだったら
今の子どもたちがテレビで歌うんだったらば
すぐチャンネル変える
苦労しながら見る聴く必要はないんだと
なぜならば まるっきり下手だから歌うの
で まあ歌の世界で残っている年取ってのけ者人々が歌う時は聴く
なぜ残っているかというと
やっぱり歌唱力がありまして歌えるんですね
だったら まあこれ普通の人間にはできない
まあ歌える人だということで
まあ聴いたりはしますけど
ですから この集中力が生まれると楽しみが生まれてくる
集中力がなくなっちゃう
楽しみが消えちゃう 世の中で人間が一番面白い
一番やりたがることは何でしょうか？と調べちゃうと
それは一番集中力しやすい世界なんですね
だったらああいうくだらんものを追っかけていくんじゃなくて
あれは依存症だから 映画なければ楽しくないと
ステレオがなければ楽しくないというようなれば依存症なんですね
だったら集中力だけ育てれば一番便利で早いんですね
で じゃあそこで問題は
じゃあ集中力では喜悦感
楽しみ 幸福感が生まれてくる
でも脳細胞はある一つのものにぎゅっと絞るでしょ
智慧が生まれるかないかってことなんですね
それもお釈迦様の立場から見れば智慧が生まれてこないなんですね
全く生まれてこないというわけではなくて
大体生まれてこないんですね
大体 なぜならば 本を読む場合は脳の一部しか使ってないんですね
映画を見る時も脳の一部しか使ってないんですね
音楽を聴く時も同じ 踊る時も同じ
そういうのは人間作ったものだから
脳のほんのわずかな部分で十分なんです
映画を見る時はまず思考は要りません
ただボケーッと見ていて
向こうは我々に思考させる
ですから 見る機能と聞く機能だけあれば十分なんです
そういうものは生まれ続けて過ぎてるんだからね
だから 何の研究教育もなしに映画見られるんです
音楽の場合も同じなんです
聞く機能だけあれば十分ですね
だから音楽を聴くために学校に行って勉強する必要はないので
勉強する人はバカなんです
まあやってますけどね
必要ないんです そういうのはもう
で 本の場合は まあちょっと言葉とかね
色々勉強しなくちゃいけないんだけどね
だから映画見るより本を読む時は知識が増える可能性は当然ありますけど
やっぱりそれでも脳の一部しか使ってないんですね
そういうことで この集中力の場合はもう楽しみが生まれてきます
苦しみも消えちゃう 悩みも消えちゃう
ものすごい幸福ですごい楽しく楽しみを感じて
喜悦感を感じて生活はできます
依存症はまるっきりないんだから
何もなくても ただ心なんとかで整えれば
もうそこで楽しみが生まれてくる
だから私は口癖で使っている脳細胞を全部使ってくださいということはなくなっちゃうんですね
全部使わなくてもできるんです
サマーディの世界では
それで この今のことでは
まっすぐ見る時も 横にちらちらと見る時でも
きちんと知恵を使う 確認して承知の承知しながら
承知っていうのはこの承知じゃないでしょうね
二通りあります  もう一つ何でしたっけ？ 受覚という字で受けて知るっていう
この承知っていうのは正しく知る
知る だから受けて知るっていうのは受動的で
相手から来た時に受け止めて知ること
承知ってここのは正しく知るって字の通りに解釈すればそういう風になると思うんです
だから承知したわよっていう時は
相手から何か言われた時にわかったわよ
だから私の立場どころ
日本のこの 2つの装置でもいいということなんです
日本語で言えばものすごい意味が違うかもしれませんだけど
どっちの承知でもいいんです
正しく知る方がグレードが高いと思う
でも情報は外から来るんだから
きちんと受け取って知ることで
きちんと受けて正しく知ると
まあそれで行く時も 何て言いますか
下がる時も まっすぐ見る時も
横に見る時というのは
そういう言葉遊び ちょっとした文学的な言葉で
何をするにしたっても
いつでもこの確認する機能を使ってくださいと
で 体を曲げて伸ばしたり曲げたりする時もちゃんとやってください
次にサンガーティパッタチーバラダーラネ
それはお坊さんのことですから
サンガーティっていうのは衣のことで
パッタっていうのはサンガーティっていうのは上の衣
あまり着ないで ただ肩にかけて持っていく
何かあったら着るという衣が 1つあります
で パッタっていうのは鉢のこと
チーバラっていうのは
私は今着ている衣とこの衣なんですね
普通に使っている衣 で
そういうものをダーラネ
着る時は 持つ時は で 在家の方々にはもうもうじゃあ関係ないと
衣を持ってないんだから
ねぇ よかったね その時もちゃんと確認しながら認知しながら承知の上でやると
だからそれは出家の人々に言ってるんですけど
普通の人も服を着る時
脱ぐ時 だからお坊さんだから鉢を持つんだけど
普通の人はカバンを持つとかね
アクセサリーを着けるとかいろいろありますからね
仕事多いと思いますけどね
我々よりは ちゃんとサンパジャナカーリホーティ
それからアシテピーテカーイテ
アシテっていうのは食べることかな
ピータって飲むこと 食べるにも飲むにも噛むにも味わうにも
でサンパジャナカーリホーティ
それからウッチャーラパッサワカムメサンパッカムメサンパジャナカーリホーティ
それは大弁小便をするにも
装置を持って行動します
それからガテティテニシンネすってジャーガリテバシテトゥンニバーウェサンパジャナカーリホーティ
ガテ歩く時 ティテ止まってる時
ニシンネ座ってる時 スッテ寝ている時
ジャーガリテ目覚めている時
バハシテ喋る時 トゥンニバーウェ何も喋ってない
黙ってる時もいつでもこの承知という機能を使ってください
だからこれ大変な仕事なんです
ものすごい難しいんです
何一つももう抜けてないんだから
何をしてもきちんと確認して
きちんとそれをよく感じて
よく理解 能力使ってやりなさいと
それでどうなるかというと
1つに集中するんじゃなくて
人間というのは使っているいろんなことに脳のいろんな部分使ってますからね
例えば横に寝ようとする
寝ようとするのは脳の働きが違うんです
目覚めたりする 横になって寝付かないでただいる時の脳の働き
座ってる時の働きというのはそれぞれ違うんですね
喋ってる時の心の働きと
何も喋らないでいる時の心の働きというのはかなり違いますから
その時その時確認しちゃうと
これなかなか大変難しいんですけど
どうなるかというと ある種ごく一般的に使っている脳細胞を 1つのから使わなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
だからこれじっと集中してやっちゃいますから
楽しみもあります 苦しみも悲しみも消えます
同時に全部能力はいつでも起動状態にあるようになっちゃう
ものすごい幅広くなっちゃうんですね
だからサマーディ瞑想とヴィパッサナーの違うところはそこら辺なんです
脳の使い方 サマーディ瞑想の場合は
たった一部だけ使えばもう究極的な気絶感を感じられます
この場合はそんな簡単にはできないんです
すごい力が必要なんです
だから 24時間体制になっちゃうんですね
確認する作業 そこで自分の体のことをそうやってじーっと長い間確認しちゃうと
全部働きは見えてくる
そうする他人にも映ってみる
みんな同じことだと これはもう蛇にしたって
モカズにしたっても 足の差があるかもしれませんだけど
同じことだと 心の働きも同じですよと
蛇が寝る時でも 人間が寝る時でも
こういう心の働きでしょうと
食べたりする時でも同じことですよと
みんな同じなんですね
だから観察すると なんとなくその自分のことを知ってるんだから
他の生命のこのその差も分かってきます
それですごい幅広く知恵が生まれてくるんです
分かりやすいことの 例えば大便小便の場合は
人間のやり方 自分の体の感覚
その時なぜ大便したくなる？なぜ小便したくなるかと
その時の感覚をちゃんと確認しておいて
その仕事をしている時の感覚をちゃんと確認しておく
じゃあカラスやらハトやらね
同じことやってますけど
それどういう感覚かすぐわかるはずなんです
ハトでもカラスでも飛んでる時でもやっちゃいますでしょうね
ほんの瞬間でしょ  1秒もかからないです
ですから 人間にその時に生まれるその感覚が
いわゆる大便か小便かしたいというその体の感覚っていうのは
あの鳥たちには瞬間しか生まれませんね
だから排出する感覚は鳥たちには瞬間しかないんですね
それだけじゃないんです
1 日何回ですか？鳥は
で 回数はだいたい数えたことはないと思いますけど
まあ食べては出す 食べては出すでしょ
とにかく 何回かと決めてないんですね
まあせいぜい回 回以上はやるでしょうね
で やるならば その鳥は一日中はどういうふうにその感覚は生まれて消えて生まれて消えてきた
人間にとっては一日一回
二回ぐらいで終わっちゃうんだけど
でもそれも長い時間かかっちゃう
それで鳥の場合は小便大便一緒でしょ
別に鳥はおしっこしませんからね
犬はやってますけど で
でも細胞を持ってる生命体だから
感覚は同じはずなんですね
ですからまあそういう風にこの
そのその生命見ても まあこういう風に感覚でしょうということは分かってきますよね
まあそれはまあ一人一人で瞑想して実践しなくちゃいけないんだからね
あまり説明しない方がいいと思います
で まあそうやって他の人のことを見てみる
それからこれ 一般的な行為としてまっすぐ歩く
あるいは前に歩く 下がる
まっすぐ見る ちらちらと横に見る
そういういろんなことをみんなやっていて
その時その時の感覚は一般論として取ってみる
それでどうなるかというと
それからその生滅ですね
こういうことで現れる
こういうことで消えるという
その昨日見たところで
そんなもんかという そんなもんかと
そこでこのほんのわずかなこのアッティカーヨーティワーパナッサ
まあ身体っていうのはそんなもんだよというサティが生まれていきます
ヤーデーワニャーナマッタイ
ほんのわずかな智慧が生まれてくる
パティッサティマッタイ
ほんのわずかな落ち着きが生まれてくる
アニッシートーチャヴィーハレティ
もうとらわれることなく生活できるね
キンチローケーウパ 家の中で何一つも執着することはなくなっちゃう
エワンピコービッカウェービクカーイカーヤヌパッシ
そのようにも体の瞑想できるんだと
で それから七番目 この七番振ってるところなんで
七番目ではなくて で 今説明したところは大変幅広いんです
この招致の部は ですから
このやりにくいかもしれませんだから
呼吸瞑想でやってみるとかね
一つ選んでやってみるとこから
それから歩く瞑想でやってみるとかね
そうやって一つ取ってやってみて
それからどんどんどんどんどんどん全ての行動をやってみるという風にやった方がいいと思いますけどね
で 体の瞑想なんですけど
あの もっと難しいんですけどね
プナチャパランビッカウェービクイマメバカーヤンウッダンパダタラアドーケーサマッタカ
タタパリヤンタンプーランナーナッパカーラッサアサチノーパッキャレッキティ
プナチャパランビッカウェー
またビクラよ 比丘がこのようにイマメバカーヤン
この体 自分の体にするとかな
イマメバカーヤン この体って意味で
どっちの体とあまりわからないんですけど
ウッダンパダタラ 足の裏から上
アドーケーサマッタカ
ケーサマッタカというのは髪の毛
髪の毛から下 髪の毛から下
足の裏から上というこの体
だからお釈迦様の言葉さえもすごい客観的なんです
全然主観的な言葉一つも使ってないんですね
イマメバカーヤンと ディスボディだからこの体
客観視で見ているんですね
アッタノーカーヤンという自分の体のことを使ってないんです
ずっとこの説明はもう客観的に言ってるんですね
だからこの仏教の人々にとってはこんなものは当たり前であって
もう主観ということはもう小さい時からないように
もうとにかくまあ頑張ってるんだから
あの 他の人々にとってはこれなかなか大変ですけどね
まあ一応経典っていうのは全てこの客観的な立場で物事を見ているんです
きっと主観的には見てない
微かでもないんです で
ですからこの体 だからスペースってここから下
ここから上というふうなね
その見方さえも客観的な見方なの
で タチャパリヤンタン
それで上と下言ったんだから
周りも言わなくちゃいけないんですね
周りは皮膚 皮膚で回ってまあ囲まっている
その中にいろんなものをプーラン
もういっぱい えっと 満たしても満たすというか
まあいっぱい色んなものが入ってるんですね
それは何が入ってる？ナナッパカーラサアスチノ
あまり気持ちのいいものじゃない
だからアスチというのスチっていうのは清らかな
素晴らしいということで
本当はあまり気持ちのいいものではない
だからアスチと不浄というんですね
だから不浄と言っただけで
ものすごい汚くて醜いという意味って
そんな主観的な意味ではないんです
素晴らしい 清らかな 大事なという意味ではないんですね
まあまあ ちょっと汚いよ
見たくないものだという感じでね
だからこのこの今箱のことを説明しました
上と下と周りはこういう箱
その箱はいっぱいもの詰まってます
この箱の中に そのものは本当はもうちょっとあまり見たくないものですよと
不浄なものですよ それをパッチョルって見てみると
どのように見るかというと
まあこの体にアッティーいますミンカーイ
この体にはあります ケーサ
髪の毛 ローマ 体の毛 ナカ
脛 ダンタ 歯 タチョ 皮膚
マンサン 筋肉 ナハールというのは何でしたっけ？スジ？アッティー
骨 アッティミンジャ 骨髄
ワッカンは腎臓かな ハデヤンは心臓
ヤカナンはあれ何でしたっけ
肝臓 キローマカン  肋膜
あ 肋膜 はい あ キローマカン
肋膜 そうそう ピヘカン
脾臓  脾臓 パッパーサンは肺
うん アンタン 腸  胃  え 胃？え？アンタン
胃ですか まあ胃だけじゃなくてもう全部ね
口の下から下まで全てまとめてアンタンって読むんですね
その食道全部 ですから大腸
小腸 胃 それから上にある食道というところ
喉の下から全部アンタンという言葉にまとめてます
アンタグナンっていうのは
この腸を あの  腸間膜  腸間膜巻いてるものですね
ウデリアンっていうのは異物です
カリサン 便ですね ピッタンは流れるもので
胆汁 センマンはタン フッボーはウミ
ローヒタン 血液 セードー
汗 セードー これは次はメーデーと書いてメードー
メードーはあのまあ死亡ですね
アッスは涙 ワサーはあの
コフ 皮膚の上に出てくる油
コ？ コフ 軟膏のコフ  ああ
コフですね 皮膚の上に出てくる油
ケイローはこの唾 シンガーニカっていうのは鼻水
鼻水  鼻水 で ラシカはこの間欠-- あの
関節髄液  うん 関節の中にあるこの油みたいな液体がありますね
まあ滑液ですけどね で
それからムッタン あの尿ですね
という 32種類あります
そうやって分けてみなさいと
すごい簡単に分けてみるんです
ここのとこには あの ここ
ここまでだと脳みそは入ってない
ああ 入ってない だから 31かな
脳みそ入ってない  全くの
うん で あの これは別にこの医学的な分析ではありません
だからって間違ってるわけでもないんです
体にあるもの全部入ってるんです
でも仏教は まあ仏教的な我儘で
自分で見たい見方で分けてるんです
見てほしい見方で分けてるんです
逆に見やすい分け方でもあります
観察しやすい分け方でもあります
で まあ当時の人にはすごい観察しやすかったでしょうと思いますね
だからこの体を分解して部品部品で見てみる
それ医学的にきめ細かくやる必要はないんだと
まあ見たら まあこんなものもありますよと
ですから この あの 胃 大腸
小腸 ですから 口から下までそのセット
ただアンタンという一言葉で
食べ物流れてるものはね
それで腸見ても あの 腸っていうのはこのグニャグニャとしているでしょう
その中いっぱい線が引いてるんですね
上に膜があるだけではなくて
この飛び出せないんです
外を出そうとしたって
繋げて繋げて血管やら栄養取るものへいっぱい入ってるんで
そこのものを見たら なんかいっぱい迷惑なものいっぱいある
それはもうアンタグナンと
で 胸の見たら大きく肺が見える
心臓が見える それからこのお腹の方で膵臓と大きいやつなんでしたっけ
肝臓とか  肝臓とかね で
そういうものは見える
まあ腎臓も まあ腎臓見えると
そんな感じでもう簡単に分けていて
それからそれは硬いもの
骨とかで骨髄とかね それから流れるもの
液体 液体として固体と液体と分けて見ているんですね
固体として見るとこういうものだよと
液体といえば まあ唾液や鼻水やら涙やら
いろいろ油やらね 脂肪やらという液体があるんだと
尿とかね そこでこの関節の中も関節破っちゃったら
液体は出てくるんですね
この滑液をね 滑 滑 何て言いますか
滑液 で そういう風に皆さん見たら
すごい綺麗なものだ すごいものだとかね
とは思わないんですね
がっかりするんです その時は美人もブスも存在しないんですからね
みんな同じなんですね
そういう目で見ると それで私はこの人のすごく好きですよとかね
この人のことすごく嫌い嫌いですと言ったっても
開けてみたらそんな好きも嫌いもどっちでもないんですね
まあ人間はあなたのハートが好きです言うんだけど
心臓見せたら好きじゃないんですからね
なんであの人のこと好きです
あの人の感想が好きですよとかね
言う人がいませんだから
実際ならそういうものでしょうね
そういうセットなんですね
そういう風に見てみな見ましょうと
そういうその分けて見る
そこで例えが出てきて
［外国語］というところまで
こう 例えは別に一つ一つ説明すると
なんか言葉なくなっちゃいますから
この訳を見ましょう 訳までつけてないんですね
リクたちよ それは例えば両方の口のある袋が種子の穀物に
穀物すなわち  すなわちと
サリ モミ米 ハマって読むんですけど
お米に精製されてないモミ
殻のついた  まあサリっていうのはある米の一種なんです
細長くて赤くて すごくあの赤米でもないんですけど
あれでまた別で サリっていうのはものすごい高級な米なんです
すごい高級なんです で
似ているのはこのインドの米のバスマティという米は日本でも買えますけどね
あのインドの材料売ってるところでバスマティという米を売ってます
すごく細くて長いんです
すごい細い で なんかこの炊いてもネバネバはしませんだけど
なんか綿のように しませんだけど
なんか綿のようにふっくらするんですけどね
すごい軽いんです 日本の米なんかすごく重く感じますけど
バスマティっていうのはなんかすごく軽く感じるんです
すごい軽い感じがします
で あの水がなんかなんか不思議な米なんですけどね
それから香りもあります
すごく香りがあります
ですから まあインド料理にはピッタリ合います
インド料理自体もかなり香りがね
激しいし ですからもう両方混ぜたらすごいいい香りが出てきますからね
まあ大体インドの食文化っていうのはすごく香りを楽しむということはありますからね
香りで決めるんです だからその能力ありまして
香りで言えますよ うまくできてるかないかと
味見しなくても  あまり日本のおかずにはバスマティは合いませんだけどね
でも食べて食べられます
あれはタイ米とは違います
タイ米はちょっと香りというか
ちょっと臭いというかね
臭いというところではないんだけど
香りがないんで死んでるぐらいのことで
バスマティはかなり香りがあります
で これ米によって香りが違います
で この軽くて このバスマティは白いんです
籾殻取っても白いんです
このサーリっていうのは
もう赤い時はピンク色というかね
細長くてすごく軽い で
香りがまた違うし これ一番米の中で高級な米なんです
今はない 作るのも大変なんです
一年一回しか取れないし
で あの 何て言いますか
あれを 木じゃなくて稲
でも長いんですね 今 バングラデシュの米の種類
稲は長いんですね あれはいつも洪水だから
人の体ぐらい背が高い稲なんですね
だから稲に 米にいろいろ種類があるということでね
まあサーリっていうのはその米なんです
まあ米の中で昔から最高級だと思ってたのはサーリという米
次に  ビーヒー  ビーヒー
ビーヒーっていうのは別にもう別に種類別ではなくて
ただの籾ということなんですね
次にサーリなビーヒーな
緑豆  緑豆 それから空豆
ゴマ  ゴマ それを訳していますね
それから米に満ちており
それを目のある人が開けて
これらはサーリなんとかである
これはビーヒー そうやって緑豆であるとかね
空豆であるとか まあ分けてみると
別々に分けなくて見たらすぐわかりますと
その例えあまりこのサーリやらわからないんだったら
まあ両側開けてる何か袋に
日本のも豆種類もたくさんあるでしょうに
米はあまりないんだけど
一種類に種類しかないんだけど
あの豆だったらいろんなありますでしょうに
20種類  30種類ぐらいもいっぱい米と一緒に入れちゃえば
見ただけでわかるでしょうに
まあそんな感じで この袋だからもう満杯にもう入ってるんですね
そんな感じで体の中の部品を見てみましょうと
それでその瞑想のやり方で終わって
次にあのステレオタイプのやり方でやらなくちゃいけない
自分の体を見て 人の体を見ると
でもこの場合はケースバイケースだから
自分の心臓はどうやって見るんですかね
これ見られないんですね
でも一部一部は見られます
これはもうスネである
これは歯であるとかね
で見られるし 髪の毛ですよとかね
見られるし これ見方なんですね
見方っていうのは部品で見る
だから人間の場合は一番やりやすいのは髪の毛なんです
髪の毛を取ってみるんです
取って手で持って あ これは髪の毛やと
カットして手で取ったら別に綺麗でも何でもないんですね
自分の髪なのに その時は気持ち悪いんです
だから出家するときは
あの出家の儀式一番最初に何やるかというと
頭を剃らなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでじゃあ出家お願いしますと言ったら
あの阿闍梨さんが この師匠のお坊さんが髪の毛切るんです
一部を切って手に上げるんです
これ持ちなさいと だからじっとこの自分でこれから捨てるんだからね
髪の毛全部 その髪をじっと手で持てなくちゃいけないんですね
その間は全部もう剃ってもう終わりますけどね
そこまでその人はこれじっと持ってるんですね
あれは何のためかというと
見てみなさいということなんですね
体って何者か で 剃って終わったら
まあ体洗いますから 洗う時は捨てますけどね
それで出家する時の儀式っていうのは
ケーサーローマーナカーダンタータチョーという 5つ教えてあげるんで
それに出家なんです ケーサー言わせるんですね
まああとでケーサーローマーナカーダンタータチョータチョーダンターナカーローマーケーサーと
この逆順番で逆順で言うんです
まあ言ってそれ言って衣をあげるんですね
それでまあ一応正式的に弟子の世界に入ったことにします
すごい単純です 単純じゃなくて
このすごい深い深い どんな状況の出家儀式よりもすごい深い意味があるんですね
そこで一切の世俗的な概念を捨てるということでね
ケーサーっていうのは髪の毛
ローマーっていうのは自分で分かってる体の毛
ナカーっていうのは爪
ダンターっていうのは歯
タチョーっていうのは皮膚
この 5つを観察しなさいと
だから色々エピソードによると
出家するすぐその瞬間で阿羅漢になった人もいるんだと
髪の毛を剃り始めたらもう悟った人もいるんだというふうな
まあどこまで本当かわかりませんだけどね
そういうエピソードもあります
だから髪の毛切って剃刀で切って
まあはいというか ちゃんと持ちなさいと
やっぱりこの この不浄ということをね
汚いという 汚いというよりはね
あんまり綺麗な美しいものじゃないという感じが生まれると思いますけどね
ですから これはもう全部自分の体の 31部見ることは不可能ですからね
だから見られるものを見てほしい
客観的に 見られるものはいくらでもあります
自分の鼻水とかね 自分の尿やら大便やらね
そういうのは観察できるものはあります
決して綺麗なものではないんです
だから人間というのはこの幻覚
この世界で生活してるんだから
とにかくこの演じる演じる世界
料理も演じる世界でしょうに
いかに美しく いかに美味しく
いかに見栄がよくという風な演じる世界だけど
演じる世界は全部嘘インチキな世界なんですね
そこはもう仏教はもうカットする
演じる世界 知識の世界だからね
苦しみしか生まれてこないんですね
料理の面で物事を見ると
それだけでも専門家でしょうに
一生かかっちゃうでしょうに
他のもの勉強できなくなっちゃう
料理研究家になっちゃったら一生かかっちゃうでしょうに
いくら一生かかっても
どのように鶏のね もう鶏の肉をね
作るかっていうぐらいことのことでしょうに
どう見たって人間食べるものっていうのは決まっていて
鶏やら まあ肉の場合は鶏か豚か
何でしたっけ？牛かとかね
だからその肉はありとあらゆる方法であって
すごいすごいと バカみたいですけどね
そこでこういうところの鶏はこういう
もうこれは日本で最高級の鶏の肉や
これは日本の最高級のもう牛肉とかね
言いながら 卵はなんか名古屋でどこかで作ってるんだそうですね
すごい高いもので まあただの卵ですけどね
[笑い]それからまあ野菜にしたってもね
まあ野菜はたくさんいろいろ種類ありますけど
結局まとめてみるとね
葉っぱ食べるか あの その土の食べるか
土の中のものを食べるかとかね
まあそれぐらいのもんなんでしょうしね
ただ実を食べるかね だから実を食べるか
葉っぱ食べるか この体の方食べるか
根元 土の中に入ってる根元のものを食べるかというのも
植物の場合はね そこで料理研究家の世界に入ってみると
もう大変なこと キャベツの作り方はまあ何百万種類もあるとかね
ですから そういう幻覚の世界
幻覚の世界というのは必ず苦しみが作られる
作る世界 で 智慧の立場から見れば
まあそれぐらいに分けてみればね
それぐらいのことです
だから食べ物はどれぐらいに種類に分けられますかね
考えたこともないでしょうね
三種類なんです 動物 肉種類
肉 魚種類でしょ 野菜種類
それから？魚はもう動物だから
コックル  コックルも植物だから
動物と植物に入らない食べ物
水  水はもう別 入りません
それは牛肉-- 牛乳系統の
ミルク  ミルク系統に ものなんです
植物でもないし 動物とも言えないんですね
乳製品  乳製品 まあただそれだけの
これはまあヤギのミルク飲むか
牛のミルク飲むか まあどちら
まあチーズ食べると まあそういう系統なんです
だからまあそういう三種類なんですね
まあ人間食べるのは 仏教の在り方に酒は入りません
それはもう禁止だから
そこで幻覚を破ってほしければ
これはすごいごちそうやというだけではなくて
これはどのようなだいぶになるかと
それも観察しなくちゃいけない
だから 弁を作るための材料だけなんですね
そんなに大胆な科学的な説明とかね
大変なもう大学まであるんだから
もう栄養専門学校やらね
それだけもう弁 どんな材料で弁を作るかと
それみたいにそんな大したことない
三種類に分けられるんだからね
そういうことだから この幻覚破ることで
そんなもんかという 小さくなっちゃうんです
全てが こんな小さくなるんです
この小さくなることがポイントなんです
それで何でもわかってしまっちゃうんですね
[咳]だからこの自分の体
他人の体と見るというところでは
この瞑想の場合はやり方はね
ちょっといろいろ無理もありますからね
三十一も全部観察できない可能性あります
でも当時インドではね
いとも簡単にそういうものを見られたんですね
で 遺体ほとんどの場合じゃなくて
お坊さんたちが人が住まないものすごい森の中とか生活してるんだから
そこら辺で人が死んじゃったらもう遺体持って捨てちゃうという習慣もありましたし
ですから そちらに行って
もう解体と解剖とか解体というか
どっちかわかりませんだけど
見てみることもできます
それから あの まあテキストによると
この大体お坊さんたちとこのお墓の責任者も結構仲がいいんです
よく行ったり来たりするんだから
他の宗教と違って ブラマンとかみんな不浄だと
もう行ってはいけないんだという風に
ものすごいこの差別感なんですね
仏教だけは全然そんなことはないんです
遺体は不浄だと思わないんです
瞑想対象なんです こちら不浄
不浄と言うんだけど その不浄の感覚が違うんです
ですから お坊さんたちは瞑想する場所としても墓場を選んだりもする
人は来ないし まあ大体葬式の人が死んじゃったら来て
また早く帰っちゃいます
インド人ってすごく迷信の塊だから怖いんですね
もう墓場に行くことさえも
ヒンドゥ教だったらすっごく怖がるんですね
ですから このもう遺体をなんとか処分して早く行く
帰る それから遺体の処理する人々は
まあなんとかお金か何か払って
もうもういるんですね
まあ今もそういう仕事はありますけどね
それはその人々はする
親戚も遺体なんか触ろうともしない
ですから この大変激しいんですね
その世界では このジャイナ教でもね
釘は教えてるんだけど
遺体を見て瞑想するっていうことはしてなかったんです
それ仏教だけなんですね
いろんな瞑想はみんな同じことやってる
例えば呼吸瞑想なんてのはヒンドゥの人々もやってましたからね
で この瞑想は仏教だけの瞑想なんですね
インドではどこにもないんです
仏教の文化だけやっている瞑想
だからもうお墓にはよく行く
お坊さんたちのお寺の一部みたいなもんなんですね
お墓っていうのは だからってお寺ではお墓作れません
お墓は別です それは人のもの
そちらに行って瞑想する
お墓と教会一緒になっているのは
まあ西洋なんですけどね
まあそれはまあ 宗教はね
まあ遺体運び屋だと思っているんだからね
死んだ人の魂を運ぶ宅急便屋さんだから
だからまあ宗教のまあ黒猫とかね
まあその 同じ宅急便屋さんなんです
霊を運ぶと あの世に で
まあ仏教はそういうことをしませんだからね
まあお寺にはお墓はないんですね
で だからといって このものすごい誰よりもお墓の見張り番とは仲がいい
ですから 昔 このいろいろストーリーにあるんですね
あのいくつかストーリーありまして
このお墓にいる人が何か遺体なんか入っちゃったら
それまあお金ある人は火葬させますけど
ない人はそのままそっちで置いたりする
それでお坊さんたちに言うんですね
今日はもう品物が入りましたと
言ったら そのお坊さんがこれを二
三週間見て 瞑想したければ置いておくんです
冥想頑張ってくださいと
そういうことあったんだからね
それからこの インドではね
この火葬っていうのはすごい質素なやり方でやってます
ほんのちょっとしか薪使わないんですね
ですから このどうせ任せて帰っちゃいますから
この見張りの人も商売だからね
大量に薪を持ってきて回しちゃうと
もう商売にならないんですね
だからまあそれぐらいほんの少々薪を持ってきて
遺体をもう切るんです
切って焼くんですね だから体っていうのはもう火がついちゃったら燃えますから
だからその日では燃えません
置いておくんです 水分が出ていくまで
油だけ残ると そこで切ってもう出せばもうあまりいりません
薪なんかは そのまま燃える
ですから 内臓を見たいお坊さんにとっては
もう大変簡単に見られるんですね
だから今はまあ一応人間の生き方は変わりましたから
まあなかなか難しいんですけどね
でも一部一部だけは見られる
見て そこはまあ見て まあ自分の体にも全く似ているものがあるんだと
全く違うものではないんだと
心臓はどんな人の心臓であって
別にあの金持ちの心臓はまあ違うものでできていて
貧しい人の心臓は違うもできてるわけじゃないんですからね
違うもできてるわけじゃないんですからね
まあただの心臓だと 肺はただの肺だと
これ誰でも同じなんです
それで不思議なことでカエルの肺も肺なんですね
だからみんなもう見てるでしょ
そう もう学校で解剖したりするとね
もうカエルの心臓にしたって
もうただ小さいだけで
かなりの勢いで行動してるでしょ
人間と比べたらスケールが小さいだけでも
まあそういうふうに自分の体でも他人の体でも
まあそれしかないんだよと思ったら
そこで欲ももうもう煩悩ももうなくなっちゃうんですね
あの人のことを愛してますよとか
そんな世界観もいきなり消えてしまっちゃうんですね
その世界で見ると そうすると
もう人間であろうが動物
生命 動物であろうか すごい単純になるでしょ？小さくなるでしょ？あるのは種一種類しかないということ
皮膚は皮膚ですからね
カエルの皮膚もトカゲの皮膚も猫の皮膚も
もうただの皮膚 猫にしたっても
毛がいっぱい生えてると可愛いんですけど
毛が抜けてみたら可愛くも何ともないですよ
迷惑だけでね 鼻に入っちゃったらもうもう風邪を引いちゃうし
風邪を引くというかね
鼻水が出るし 喘息になっちゃうし
本当はもうあまり好ましくないものなんですね
ですから 本当にそうやって部分部品化して見るんだっていうことで
それで自分の体見て 他人の体見て
ループを見て どのように現れるかと
体がどのように成長しているかというと
こういろんな食べ物を入れることで成長して
それからどんどん消えていくということとかね
観察していく それでそんなもんかという智慧が生まれてくるんですよ
体っていうのはそんなもんでしょうと
智慧が生まれてくると
[咳]えーと 次のセットは何でした？次にダハトゥから
あ これ不浄観ではなくて
もっと違う感じですね
読み方わからない これイトウ
あ 七観ですか  六観書いてるもの
音逆とか音逆とかいやですね
音逆観察 逆に見るっていうことで
この感じはいいんですね
今は通ってます 不浄観と書くよりはね
これ逆さまにして見るというのは
この人間とはこれ逆さまにして見るんじゃないんです
本当は正しく見るんです
正しく見るとこんなもんです
でも人間が変に見てるんだから
その人間の変な見方から見て
これは音逆観になってます
別に仏教の人々は物事は変に逆さまにしてみているわけじゃないんです
人間に皮膚がないと誰が言うんですかね
心臓がないと誰が言うんですかね
大便 小便ないと誰言うんですかね
これ正しい見方で 全ての生命はそんな問題で見てるんだから
まあその次にこの様相観察の部ですね
で どこですかね 何ページかな
あ 三ページ 終わって四ページ
落ちてるのかな これ何と何だ
えーと そこの次七でしょ
三ページの下 三ページの下から四行目にあります
それあの三十二でしょ
三十一の説明でしょ 三ページ終わって四ページに行ってみても続きで
パティックーラ・マナシカーラ・パッバンと
このあの音逆観 そこで終わっちゃうんですね
四ページの真ん中辺に七つ
あ はいはいはい ああ いやいやあります
あります 八番目 ロンペイジのハチバンメン
プナチャパラン
ビッキャウェー ビッコー イマメヴァカーヤン ヤターティタング ヤタパニヒタング ダートゥソー パッチャウェッカティ
アッティー マスミン カーエー パタヴィー ダートゥ アポー ダートゥ テージョー ダートゥ ワーヨー ダートゥ
というところ それから
セイヤターピ ビッキャウェー ダッコー ゴーガータコー ワー ゴーガータ カンテー スー ワー ガーヴィン
ワー ワー ガーヴィン ワディットゥワー チャトゥンマハパテー キール ソー ヴィバジットゥワー ニッシンノー
アッサエヴァメヴァ コー ビッキャウェー ビッコー イマメヴァカーヤン ヤターティタング ヤタパニヒタング
ダートゥソー
パッチャウェッカティ アッティー マスミン カーエー パタヴィー ダートゥ アポー ダートゥ テージョー ダートゥ ワーヨー ダートゥティ
これすごい短いんです
この要素に分けてみると
要素っていうのはもう
あの 地水火風なんですね
それはもうそれ以上縮むことはできない
存在すべてのものは 地っていうのは硬いもの
水っていうのは まあ流れるもの
火っていうのは火のこと
風っていうのは まあ風のこと
空気のことなんですね
そういう風に理解したっても十分なんです
この厳密にこの仏教的に地水火風の理解なくたっても
ただまあ硬い部分と流れる水のような部分と
まあ火と熱と それから空気と
だからどんな立場を取っても構いません
例えばこの普通の学校で言うでしょ
物の存在っていうのは三つですよとね Solid Liquid Gas
でしょ Solidっていうのはまあ硬い Liquid
っていうのはもう液体
でGasでしょ Gas
は何？気体 それに熱入れれば四つだから
ですから そういう風に単純に見たっても一向に構いません
で 厳密に地の元素なんでしょうか
水の元素なんでもうあんまりそこまで行く必要ないと思いますけどね
一応この四つに分けてみようと
この体をね この体には硬い部分がある
だからその瞑想しやすくするのは
その三十一はあの順番で分けてます
三十一の中にあるのは
この固体と液体だけ そこに入ってないのは火と風なんですね
で 火と風を加えれば四つになるんですね
そこでこの体に地の要素あるんだと
硬い要素があるんだと
それ流れる液体的な要素があるんだと
で 熱という要素があるんだと
それから空気という要素があるんだと
どう見たっても その四つでこの体ができてるんですね
体の中に熱があって また空気もいろんなところに入っていて
まあそれぐらいですよ
それは自分の体を見て
他の体見たっても地水火風しかないと
どんな体見たっても地水火風ですよ
硬いものと液体のものと熱と空気と
それで体ができているんだと
アメーバ見たってもその要素なんですね
そこの例えばこの例と
例えばおしょうし 例えば熟練したー
屠牛者  屠牛者かその弟子が
牛牛  牛牛を殺し 次第なんとか
切り抜い  牛尾字で  牛尾字で
切り裂いて  切り裂いて座ってるようなものですと
僕たちのちょうどそのように
比丘はこの身をあるがままに
置かれたままに要素から観察します
この身には地の要素 水の要素
火の要素 風の要素があると
まあすごいまあ恐ろしい例えでね
まあ牛を殺して色々分けて肉っていうのは分けて売ってるもんだからね
色々部品に分けて売ってるような感じで
体も分けて あの 見てみなさいと
それは自分の体であっても他人の体見たっても同じことですよと
で なぜ地の要素を生まれ出たか
なぜ火の要素を生まれ出たかっていうふうなことを見なさいと
どのように消えていくかっていうことを見てみなさいと
そこでこれぐらいというね
アッティカーヨーティワー パナサティパッティパッティダーオ
まあ体っていうのはこれぐらいのもんだよという理解が生まれてくる
すごく小さくなるでしょ
体っていうか生命ってすごい小さくなる
地水火風になってしまう
これくらいだと そこは智慧なんですね
そこで落ちつきが生まれてくる
執着なし 世の中で生きていることはできますね
で あ 今日はまああの それで最後にまあ九日残りますけど
この体の瞑想はね まあそれまあそんなに時間かからないと思いますけどね
まあ今日はもう時間ですので
終了します